bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver à
la une de ça vous regarde ce soir à
peine démarré déjà menacé la cgt a
claqué la porte ce matin de la
conférence de financement de la réforme
des retraites elle dénonce un compromis
impossible avec le gouvernement à
l'assemblée c'est aussi la bronca sur
tous les bancs de l'opposition n'est pas
loin du blocage la discussion est
totalement enlisé dans des batailles de
procédures retraites le débat impossible
c'est la question du grand débat ce soir
sur ce plateau la nouvelle est ma verra
bien le jour en 2020 deux fois du
premier ministre edouard philippe
comment ce symbole de l'entre- soi et de
la reproduction des élites va-t-il faire
sa mue ouverture à la diversité tronc
commun pour les futurs hauts
fonctionnaires on va en parler ce soir
avec celui qui a planché pendant des
mois sur cette réforme
frédéric thiriez est notre invité et
puis il ne s'est pas expliqué depuis que
son syndicat a quitté la table des
négociations dans cette bataille des
retraites il joue gros très gros
sa stratégie peut-elle payer la rue
contre le gouvernement alors que le
mouvement s'essouffle philippe martinez
et notre grand témoin ce soir voilà donc
pour le programme c'est parti hashtag
sévère n'oubliez pas où il va
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
nos invités en plateau ce soir philippe
martinez bonsoir j'ai et merci donc
d'être notre grand témoin le jour où
votre syndicat quitte les négociations
cette fameuse conférence de financement
qui vient de démarrer avec l'ensemble
des partenaires sociaux vous nous dire
évidemment pourquoi vous avez pris cette
décision on va y revenir longuement
votre regard aussi sur cette impasse à
l'assemblée nationale sur les retraites
nous intéresse aussi on en parle ce soir
avec vous jacquemet rebond soit vous
êtes député la république en marche des
hauts-de-seine l'un des rapporteurs de
la réforme des retraites est là
faucillon bonsoir et bienvenue député
communiste des hauts de seine et
dominique corona bonsoir vous êtes
secrétaire général adjoint de l'unsa qui
participent toujours à cette conférence
de financement l'unsa-transports en
revanche avaient appelé à une journée
noire à la ratp qui s'est soldée par un
échec on va y revenir merci à tous les
quatre de participer à ce ça vous
regarde en direct je vous donne la
parole dans un instant mais celui qui
ouvre le bal
c'est stéphane stéphane blakowski dans
son billet si j'ai bien compris tout de
suite
[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous comme on soit
stéphane installez-vous si j'ai bien
compris ce soir et ben si j'ai bien
compris myriam la cgt ne lâchera rien
elle est bien décidée à aller jusqu'au
bout pour faire annuler cette réforme
des retraites alors évidemment on dit
posé comme préalable l'annulation de la
réforme
ça laisse peu de marge de négociation
mais après tout c'est vrai que à partir
du moment où on est d'accord sur rien
c'est la cgt et le gouvernement n'ont
aucune position conciliables à quoi bon
se rallier autour d'une table à c'est un
petit peu ce que disait ce matin
catherine perret sur radio classique
la conférence des financements est morte
mais c'est pas une surprise pour la cgt
puisque dès le départ à partir du moment
où le premier ministre avait fixé comme
objectif de ne pas augmenter les
cotisations sociales
évidemment il ne restait qu'un paramètre
c'est l'âge pivot ce qui me ce qui
m'alerte c'est que le medef et le
gouvernement s'est même combat et
d'ailleurs la cgt compte tenu de cette
absence de possibilité de travailler
sérieusement pour financer les
améliorations des droits dans le cadre
du régime actuel a décidé de quitter la
conférence de financement voilà alors
comment a réagi le gouvernement à cette
annonce était spécialement émue j'ai
l'impression le seul qui était vraiment
un peu surpris c'est yves veyrier le
patron de force ouvrière qui dès ce
matin dans le figaro
je comprends pas philippe martinez m'a
pas du tout prévenu de son intention de
quitter la conférence
bon je sais pas vous répondrai tout à
l'heure mais en tout cas côté
gouvernement veut pas de surprise nous
regrettons donc la décision de la cgt
mais au fond nous considérons qu'elle
n'est pas vraiment surprenante compte
tenu de l'opposition de principe qui a
eu cette organisation syndicale à la
réforme des retraites
alors est-ce que ce départ de la cgt va
peu tort pillés cette conférence de
financement moi j'ai l'impression que
les français sont plutôt habitués au
fait que la cgt le gouvernement soit
jamais d'accord sur rien donc c'est pas
vraiment une surprise en preuve celui
qui pourrait en revanche torpiller la
conférence
c'est laurent berger de la cfdt ce kit
est ainsi claqué la porte
la wii la préférence rhéteur pillés
d'ailleurs je pense que berger a l'air
conscient un petit peu de ce rapport de
force avec le gouvernement puisque dans
le jdd ce week-end il disait
attention ce n'est pas parce que ça
s'appelle conférence de financement
qu'il faut considérer que l' équilibre
financier doit être la priorité donc on
en revient à une opposition
traditionnelle entre syndicalistes
réformiste et syndicalistes plus
contestataire alors ne contestons pas le
fait que la cgt soit plus tôt
contestataires mais on peut pas dire non
plus que la cgt est opposée par principe
à tout ce que dit gouvernement sans
jamais rien proposer
au contraire il les force à eux d'avoir
une alternative ce matin catherine
perret disait attention on n'est pas en
dit pas juste non on avec
l'intersyndicale on va faire une
conférence alternative pour trouver un
autre solution pour trouver l'équilibré
financier donc voilà quelques pistes
qu'elle a qu'elle annonçait il ya plein
d'argent possible est disponible dans ce
pays on a réussi nous a dégagé à peu
près 85 milliards d'euros par an
simplement en menant une politique sur
les salaires sur la qualité de l'emploi
sur l'égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes
en mettant fin aux exonérations en
taxant les entreprises particulièrement
les grosses entreprises
alors au bout du compte à votre avis
est-ce que la cgt a une chance de faire
plier le gouvernement sait pas comment
miser là dessus mais bon pour l'instant
de dire que c'est pas gagné à ce que la
mobilisation des manifs et plutôt en
baisse le biais de grève générale a pas
vraiment pris on sent que certains
adhérents de la cgt se radicalise un peu
il ya des blocages les opérations entre
d'autres syndicats mais tout ça n'a pas
l'air très efficace et en fait je me
demande si la cgt
et bien sûr c'est juste une question
devrait pas s'interroger un petit peu
sur l'efficacité de ces méthodes puisque
quand on reprend la liste des fortes
mobilisations en 2016 mobilisation
contre la loi elle comme ribbons ce
échec
en 2010 cette mobilisation de fonds les
ordonnances macron échec en 2018
mobilisation contre la réforme de la
sncf et chaque bond 2019 de l'année du
gilet jaune la cgt passe à côté cette
année si en 2020 il ya encore un échec
de la mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites va commencer à faire beaucoup
alors il a lancé un peu facile de dire
ça de l'extérieur mais on se dit est ce
qu'il serait pas temps de remettre un
petit peu en cause le plan de l'action
de la cgtr martinez avait lancé une
consultation cet été auprès des
adhérents 10 ans mais ballon voir
comment on pourrait peut-être changer
tout ça pour des clous andré bélec
martinelli résultat ne peut pas trop
savoir ce qu'en pensent les gens de la
cgt en revanche si un sondage qui a été
fait par le cevipof
c'est un truc de science po
d'études politiques ils ont demandé aux
français mais pourquoi selon vous il ya
une défiance vers les syndicats en
france pourquoi il ya si peu de
syndiqués en france réponse numéro un
parce que les syndicats sont trop
politisé alors voilà c'est juste une
hypothèse évidemment mais si la cgt a
perdu son rôle de premier syndicat de
france par rapport à la cfdt
je me demande si c'est pas parce
qu'aujourd'hui la cgt est plus perçue
comme une organisation politique qui
combat le gouvernement plutôt qu'une
organisation syndicale qui combat pour
les salariés alors ya beaucoup de choses
dans le biais de ces femmes et on va
reprendre point par point c'est du
réchauffé quand même un cd commentaires
qu'on doit entendre depuis 20 ans pour
mais depuis vingt ans la cgt n'a pas
beaucoup évolué faut dire martinez
depuis le début depuis les débuts de ce
bras de fer sur les retraites
vous avez toujours accepté de vous
rendre aux invitations du gouvernement à
discuter toujours vous dites toujours si
vous vous rendez conviés ce soit à
l'elysée que ce soit avec les
partenaires sociaux
vous y allez pourquoi la cgt s'en va
aujourd'hui premièrement la cgt elle
était présente hier
vous savez qui était absent hier les
deux ministres en charge du dossier qui
fait la politique de la chaise vide
les deux ministres nouveau d'ailleurs
donc qu'ils ont je sais bien qu'ils
maîtrisent les dossiers mais les deux
seuls absents hier c'était les deux
ministres plus vous êtes plus or contre
la cgt l'avocat des mini les gens qui
n'auraient pas là on écoute philippe
martinez et donc je vous dis les deux
seuls absents
c'est vrai sur quelque chose d'essentiel
la conférence de financement les deux
seuls absents c'était les deux ministres
en charge est aussi ça c'est la première
chose dont kirk est ce que nous avons
fait je vous ai ramené les documents et
on est les seuls à l'avoir fait on a
expliqué pourquoi les fameux 12
milliards qui d'ailleurs pour la fin de
la réunion se sont transformés en 113
milliards dans une inflation et des 2
milliards de déficit du corps à corps
le gouvernement a certes 13 ans 13 faut
être prêt si on était à la réunion donc
on a bien écouté donc il ya une
inflation du déficit des caisses de
retraite
entre début de la réunion et la fin on
est passé de 12 à 113 on a donc démontré
par un expert indépendant qui n'est pas
la cgt qui s'appelle michael zemmour qui
a démontré
au tableau noir que ce déficit était sûr
fait la deuxième chose on a fait des
propositions
voilà je voulais vous les montre ça a
été présenté hier à la conférence de
financement vous voyez que la cgt fait
des propositions on a été les seuls mais
seuls notez le j'ai vu vos sites
internet j'ai vu les propositions sur
nos télés parce que vous l'avez oublié
de le dire on a laissé par catherine
pour financer le système des retraites
avec votre réforme annoncée n'est pas
évidemment c'est pour améliorer le
système actuel parce que nous
considérons que ce système à des
intersections puisque évidemment n'est
pas la même situation qu'eux on était à
la libération
et puis des gouvernements successifs ont
fait en sorte que les recettes
s'amoindrissent et donc on a des
problèmes de financement donc on a fait
des propositions concrètes et donc je
finis des propositions concrètes avec le
financement qui va avec
donc on est confronté à deux
propositions celle du gouvernement et
celle de la cgt donc il ya des choix à
faire
or vous le savez bien vous l'avez
rappelé enfin tout cas catherine perret
l'a rappelé le medef et le 1er mai se
disent il faut pas toucher aux salaires
il faut pas toucher aux salaires donc on
nous dit vous pouvez dire ce que vous
voulez mais passa passa passa 7,7
cette modalité de conférences de
financement c'est nous qui l'avons
demandé les modèles les modalités on
avait demandé mais on n'était pas passé
à la télé pour le dire nous les
modalités c'est nous et premier qui nous
a dit oui vous venez avec vos experts et
on fera projet contre projet c'est ce
que nous avons fait c'est seulement le
dialogue possible avec le gouvernement
le gouvernement doit faire des choix on
faire le gouvernement doit faire des
choix soit il donne raison mais nef soit
il écoute les syndicats
c'est ce que nous allons voir sauf que
il ya trois réunion de prévue vous le
savez ça doit finir fin avril nous
sommes interpellés par des députés
j'étais en audition ce matin qui nous
disent on nous propose
on nous dit on vous discuté d'une loi on
va discuter d'une loi et on va voter une
loi et vous vous à côté vous discuter
des financements et vos résultats
si j'ai bien compris on les connaîtra
repris après le vote de la loi
donc on a dit bah accélérant le
mouvement est donc on est capable en une
seule réunion de dire voilà pourquoi n'y
a pas de déficit sur les caisses de
retraite et voilà les propositions
concrètes vous êtes en dehors donc
maintenant de cette conférence de
financement avec les partenaires
question vous donné par alliance vos
propositions sous forme d'amendement
laissez moi qu'est ce qu'a voulu dire
catherine perrin accèdent maintenant la
balle est dans le camp du gouvernement
il faut répondre rapidement à ces deux
projets pour que les députés puissent
faire des choix en connaissance de cause
et donc on va de nouveau interpellé le
gouvernement disant dépêchez vous de
donner votre avis sur ce qu'on vous a
proposé et on verra ce qu'on fait la
prochaine réunion et dans trois semaines
si je me proposais l'histoire des de
l'intérieur pour vous n'est plus utile
c'est bien nous avons qu on pourrait
quand même biais dire que peser à
l'intérieur d'une conférence sociale
avec les partenaires monsieur je vous
écoute et mais je vous demande nous
avons de l'extérieur nous sommes les
seuls à l'avoir fait est qu'elle est
protégée si en quoi le déficit n'est pas
un déficit structurel c'est de la
responsabilité des gouvernements
quand on baisse les recettes forcément
après on dit faut réduire les dépenses
est ça la stratégie mais pas de ce que
de ce gouvernement là le pressent le
précédent l'a fait aussi et monsieur
juppé la fei quelques réformes sur les
retraites et nous avons fait des
propositions
la balle est dans le camp du
gouvernement puisque le premier nisme
m'a dit personnellement dans son bureau
proposez-nous un projet on fera des
choix et bien maintenant on attend la
réponse du gouvernement
je veux juste préciser qu'on est prêt à
discuter tout le monde et comme il ya un
député de la république en marche ici ça
fait trois mois qu'un de vos collègues
m'a contacté et m'a dit ça serait bien
si on pouvait faire une audition de la
cgt
trois mois j'attends toujours la réponse
malgré de nombreuses relances de ma part
en disant on est 10
vous avez un collègue qui s'appelle
imagine porter les rapporteurs sont à
disposition tout le monde
moi j'ai reçu j'ai réuni beaucoup de
gens moi prénoms et noms mais je vous
dis les rapporteurs ont été nommé il ya
quelques semaines
ah pardon absolument non mais je vous
dis et donc moi j'ai toujours été dans
les faits on a été sollicité par tout le
monde on a vu tous les syndicats qui
l'ont demandé on n'a jamais été
sollicités nous rapporteur qu'ils sont
responsables du texte paraît pas comment
ça marche voilà vous parlez entre vous
non mais je vous dis non mais vous
parlez vous venez je dis ça fait trois
mois
vous venez et lui tend la main pour
fournir des biens la cgt dont vous venez
je sais vous la connaissez bien le
répète ça fait trois mois qu'on dit
qu'on est disponible pour aller
rencontrer le groupe la république en
marche je vous disais j'ai cité le nom
du collègue qui m'a demandé je lui ai
fait trois ans mercy vous lance une
invitation vous verrez qu'en dehors je
relance de ses studios
le départ de la cgt pour le regretter
mais vous êtes n'a pas confirmé des gens
jusqu'à maintenant je vous dis je vous
dis que il hier nous étions présents
c'est la dernière année alors que cette
même réunion dominée corona la prochaine
de maiana sur le financement assumé par
le gouvernement mais parce que la
gouvernance parce qu'il ya deux groupes
de souris sur la gouvernance on avait
encore dit qu'on n'irait pas voilà
gouvernants sont effectivement que
conférence la prochaine réunion sur le
financement des finances s'est montré
dix marques sur le financement
vous peut-être vous errez selon ce qu'on
dira je vous l'avez compris ce que j'ai
dit pour aider à balai dans les contrats
ce matin on a perdu je vous prédis on
n'ira pas et vous dire la mirap tech je
vous prête noms suis pas dit on ira
peut-être je vous dis là bas est dans le
camp du gouvernement on a fait des
propositions concrètes je vous laisse il
voulait enfin je le donnais les pieds
sur internet un chanteur gérard jodar
alors comment comment vous accueillez
cette position de la cgt
j'en offre plus dire départ non mais
d'abord merci lcp d'avoir établi le
contact d'abord
mes premiers éléments pour nous d'abord
c'est qu'il ya peut-être quand j'entends
quand je vous entends monsieur martinez
et peut-être une incompréhension de ce
qui est attendu de cette conférence
conférence est pas un dialogue
non mais vous avez dit ministre n'est
pas là on assume bien que n'y soient pas
là parce que ce qui est demandé c'est
effectivement que patronat d'un côté
syndicats de l'autre se mettre d'accord
sur un dispositif de financement du
déficit jusqu'en 2027
si cet accord est la sq a dit
effectivement une barre phillips et que
on retire toute idée préalable et on
incorpore ce résultat dans le dispositif
final dit que c'est le gouvernement qui
est responsable de l'échec est pas le
medef à la limite le medef qui est
partenaire
j'ai pas dis ça je dis que la banale
dans le vert du premier ministre moi
j'ai été invité par le premier ministre
nous y avons été donc je l'avais comme
ça face à moi dans son bureau il m'a
expliqué les règles vous savez vous
confondez une négociation une
négociation collective
un accord national interprofessionnel ou
l'a6 entre les syndicats et le patronat
il ya personne d'autre il y avait un
monsieur qui s'appelle monsieur marc est
qui a été désigné par le gouvernement
donc c'est pas on n'est pas dans un cas
dans le cadre d'une négociation on est
dans le cadre d'une discussion
c'est tout à fait différent il y aura
pas de signature opa signature à la fin
de cette discussion est ce que vous
confirmez
en 15 j étais oui et je veux confirmer
qu'effectivement la cgt a présenté les
propositions mais nous avons nous-mêmes
présente certes ans de révolution
le seul problème c'est que cette réunion
c'était pour parler bordiot diagnostic
donc on va parler des du quand elles ne
mesurent que l'unsa a proposé depuis
longtemps et je sais que philippe il les
connaît nos solutions aussi et que de
toute façon dans les prochaines réunions
on parlera effectivement des mesures
proposées par les nazis en fait c'est
pas vraiment une conférence sociale
aussi d'accord une négociation à retenir
sociaux pour le dire vite entre
syndicats de salariés et patronat et le
gouvernement reprend est ce que c'est ça
ou est-ce que c'est au fond à la fin du
gouvernement qui regardent et qui
tranche et qui dit non au voile après
tarbes je vous rappelle que cette idée
de conférence est arrivé pour enlevée
l'âge pivot qui était inacceptable pour
les salariés injustement inacceptable et
donc nous avons décidé effectivement
collet
evènement nous avons proposé
effectivement qui est le conférence des
financeurs cette conférence bien sûr
elle doit faire quoi
un douzième déficit scianna et qui en
est responsable parce qu'ils sont par
exemple aujourd'hui un chiffrage en 2025
il faut effectivement pas un chiffrage
du corps en 2027 déjà parce qu'on nous a
demandé jusqu'à 2027
donc ouais effectivement et qui sont les
responsables par exemple quand vous avez
la caisse déconnecté territoriales
locales
vous avez non une inflation entre
guillemets en pourcentage des dépenses
par ce qui fait qu on est de plus en
plus de retraités en les caisses d'un
caisse locale et une baisse des recettes
vous avez un ep 6 ou qui doit payer à ce
moment là sur laquelle la cnra ciel
c'est ça les questions à laquelle va pas
du tout moi j'ai une interview à madame
je vous dire un truc je vais vous dire
en speed on l'attendait moi je vais vous
dirigez vous permettez nous sommes
optimistes nous dire pourquoi les
optimistes comme ça parce que nous
pensons que il faut aller jusqu'au bout
cette conférence parce qu'effectivement
il a l'argent à trouver de l'argent
si moi je suis d'accord et qui dit
martinez quand on va baisser les
cotisations sociales employeurs de 16,2
de 16% à 1 4% pour les plus de 10000
euros
oui à de l'argent trouvé et oui c'est
pas augmenter le coût du travail
oui de l'argent trouvé sur les quais de
la caisse locale ou à passer le 30 %
cotisation reer à 16
donc oui il ya encore d'argent à trouver
à ce niveau là oui à le fonds de réserve
des retraites où il ya 33 milliards
d'euros
oui à les cotisations sociales
employeurs parce que par exemple sur les
employeurs mais heureusement qu'il ya du
grain monde est ce qu'il ya d'important
me semble-t-il en danse tout cela c est
ce que oui ou non la démocratie sociale
peut sortir grandie est ce que oui ou
non on est capables tous ensemble malgré
nos différences nos désaccords de
trouver un bon accord pour les assurés
sociaux gouvernement mais tout le monde
parce que le gouvernement est
responsable aussi et le gouvernement ne
veut pas sauver la consanguinité sur
marie de la démocratie sociale on a deux
positions ça n'est qu'à différents un
optimiste unsa y croit encore plutôt
pessimiste confirme c'est pas un accord
national
je confirme c'est bien sûr en confiera
c'était pas une négociation est ce que
vous vous situez dans ces deux positions
là vous qui avec les communistes
demander le retrait de cette réforme
moi ce que je vois surtout c'est que
cette conférence de financement elle est
assez à l'image de la gestion par le
gouvernement et la majorité depuis le
début de cette annonce de cette
contre-réforme des retraites
c'est-à-dire l'idée et ça se voit ça
s'est vu aujourd'hui on en reparlera
mais dans l'hémicycle et une majorité un
gouvernement qui pense que ils ont
raison tout seul qui sont persuadés
qu'ils ont les bonnes solutions et qui
sont absolument sourd à ce qui s'exprime
dans le pays ce que tout à l'heure on a
regardé un sondage venant du cevipof sur
la cgt mais ça peut être intéressant de
discuter de ce que pensent les français
des syndicats mais il ya quand même
plein de sondages qui sont sortis pour
dire que la cgt était pas seul dans le
pays a contesté cette réforme que les
communistes et les députés projettera
les seuls à contester cette réforme dans
ce pays il ya une majorité qui pense que
cette réforme elle les emmène droit dans
le mur et ils ont compris qu'ils
allaient travailler plus longtemps et
avoir des pensions plus basse et il ya
un gouvernement une majorité car elle
pas de nous expliquer qu'on a tout faux
qui veulent notre bien contre notre gré
et qu'en fait ils vont nous faire du mal
donc ça suffit et le monde en face à
elle pour faire parvenir ce moment il ya
une journée d'action demain vous déférez
moi ce que je crois c'est que oui
d'abord je défilerai et ensuite je sais
pas si vous avez remarqué mais j'ai
l'impression que le mal est profond dans
le pays
on a vu la séquence gilet jaune l'année
dernière les blouses blanches
le personnel de l'éducation on a cette
mobilisation historique contre la
réforme des retraites
je crois pas que ce mal profond qui
existe aujourd'hui contre la casse des
services publics sur une aspiration tout
simplement un autre monde à une autre
vie un autre modèle eh bien je crois pas
qu'elle s'efface non seulement d'un
revers de main mais en plus avec une
attitude méprisante sourde aux
propositions puisque nous avons des
propositions et je crois pas qu'elle
s'efface de cette manière là donc oui
moi je crois qu'il ya des mobilisations
évidemment qu'ils peuvent qui peuvent
reprendre
et je crois que la partie est pas gagnée
pour le gouvernement
mr vous redoutez au fond cette majorité
alors on la voit dans les enquêtes
d'opinion on la voit pas forcément dans
la rue parce qu'on voit bien que ça
c'est un fait elle s'essouffle
progressivement mais forcément c'est
compliqué ça coûte cher de faire la
grève etc
mais est-ce que vous vous sentez ce
qu'on vous dit dans le camp d'en face un
profond rejet de cette réforme dans le
pays
bon je sens que je sente pas ça je ne
sens pas du tout un profond regret je
sens effectivement des demandes bien
particulière des inquiétudes partout
parce qu'on touche à quelque chose qui
concerne 100 % des français je sens un
besoin d'explication a besoin de débat
un besoin de clarification qui est plus
les gens se rendent compte dans
effectivement et donc de ce point de vue
de faire de voir de l'obstruction dans
nuire à tout à l'heure
cette explication est ce débat et cet
enrichissement éventuel impossible
maintenant je reviens à la conférence
nationale s'explique en fait par le
grand bluff
c'est tout l'art j'ai des oreilles qui
sont bouchés va tout de même en dessous
de vous et vous n'arrêtez pas de hurler
depuis voilà et donc il est très clair
que pour nous il ya un enjeu extrêmement
fort pour les partenaires sociaux ils en
sont tous conscients c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui
effectivement monsieur martinez c'est
pas une contractualisation c'est une
concertation pour proposer des solutions
au gouvernement et comme effectivement
une part des financements concernent des
régimes publics
le medef par exemple ne représente pas
évidemment l'employeur public donc c'est
vrai que l'exercice est un peu mixte
mais ce qui est vrai aussi c'est qui est
un engagement qui est que si on respecte
le le retour à l'équilibré en ne
touchant pas le coût du travail
je simplifie niveau des pensions dans
ces cas là les gouvernants y prends ça
veut dire ça concrètement s'il ne faut
pas gagner voilà ça veut dire salarial
entre les failles et les autres chiens
aux cotisations batterie et c'est aux
prochaines années permettant si je ne
parie arminé c'est pas possible
les emails non mais soyez prêt le coût
du travail c'est pas le niveau de la
cotisation le coût du travail ça ça
repose sur beaucoup de choses qui sont
effectivement de différents types de
cotisation c'est pas les mêmes pour le
public et pour le privé il ya
effectivement le fonds de réserve hier
d'autres choses ja il ya l'ircantec on
l'a dit enfin bien les régimes sont très
différents sur le fond de réserve
terminons me portant et pas celui là
n'est pas l'important c'est que ce qui
est proposé là de dire est ce que vous
pouvez vous même vous mettre d'accord
c'est une espèce de test grandeur nature
de ce qui va se passer pour le système
universel d'avenir et ce à tout le monde
de 7 dans cette salle c'est à dire que à
partir de 2022 et après le conseil le
conseil d'administration de la caisse
il va être un peu comme l'agirc-arrco
sauf qu'on passe de 70 milliards pour
une retraite complémentaire du privé à
320 milliards pour tous les français et
effectivement le pari qui est fake et de
deux de donner ce pilotage avec
effectivement une règle quelques règles
d'or qui sont pas de pas de remise en
cause de valeur du point qui sont un
équilibre à cinq ans si les partenaires
sociaux n'arrivent pas à trouver les
solutions pour le financement de cette
phase de démarrage
ils savent très bien que c'est lors
comment dire leur visibilité à la fois
pour eux mêmes en interne et pour
l'opinion publique sur la capacité à
gérer le paritarisme nations can agences
et ça tout le monde le sait chantage et
cette pression et de pression exception
de la discussion
c'est incroyable vous donner la solution
est à nous de faire dénoncer mais vous
avez fait ça pour l'assurance chômage
vous avez dit il faut économiser 4
milliards débrouillez vous donc les
syndicats jouent gros et le cds français
je pense que tout le monde joue groupe
absolue pour moi je pense que c'est la
société qui joue gros
mais quand je vois qu effectivement 17 %
des français pensent que les partenaires
sociaux se mettront pas d'accord
et bien moi ça me pose un problème de
démocratie en france et donc c'est tout
le monde qui joue gros c'est pas que les
partenaires sont d'accord c'est
effectivement est ce que cette réforme
que nous n'avons pas demandé de moi même
ça elle sera acceptée socialement et
vous avez donc une responsabilité aussi
lourde
ce sujet par des traits si c'est moi ce
que ce que ce que je vais vous dire
aussi c'est l'alternative
sur le mois vous allez noah l'unsa la
porte est ouverte
on s'assoit on parlera de tout on mettra
tout sur la table et si le coût du
travail
il ya un accord global sur le coût du
travail eh bien on en parlera le premier
ministre il ne faut il ne faut rien
négliger pour présenter coût du travail
augmente le coût du travail n'est pas
positionné du coût du travail parlons
des salaires c'est l'histoire éditions
révélation surmonter les salaires
proposition l'enjeu oui il y avait
effectivement une vrai débat sur la
pénibilité aujourd'hui et aujourd'hui on
est une vraie difficulté à ce sujet on
veut mettre en place des aides de la
prévention très bien dans les branches
et c'est très bien avec un fonds de 100
milliards pour la branche at mp millions
vous voulez sauf que aujourd'hui la
réparation
aussi ce n'est pas au rendez vous c'est
à dire que nous avons un medef s'est
arquebouté aujourd'hui c'est pourtant
pas pourquoi vous vous restez optimiste
on a l'impression que sur chaque
condition vous énumérer parce que par
exemple sur la sur les générations
curité 75 nous l'avions demandé une
blague en lui parce que nous pensons
infections sauvian contributif
il faut aller plus loin et que nous
allons encore grant et des trucs parce
que nous pensons nous que fasse un
pouvoir quel qu'il soit il faut que les
syndicats sont là pour défendre des
intérêts des salariés et donc tant qu'on
peut on restera et je vous dire qu'on
n'a pas fini sur des chaussures
effectués sont nos revendications c'est
soit ça soit laisser le gouvernement
mattrach pivot c'est hors de question
oulaï donc les donc à ce jour hors de
question mais attendez moi je crois que
je pense qu'aujourd'hui le medef j'ai lu
avec attention l'intervention dans les
échos de monsieur roux de bézieux
la france est le patron du medef si le
patron du medef pense qu'il faut miser
contre la conférence pour qu'elle échoue
parce qu'ils pensent que l'âge pivot
reviendra je pense qu'ils se trompent
parce que je pense que le gouvernement a
bien entendu que si effectivement
c'était l'âge
effectivement c'était totalement
désastreux pour les assurés sociaux
et quand les prémices aujourd'hui nous
dit j'ai enlevé l'âge pivot je parle de
mesures dans sa lettre de mesures ' avec
ds et d'un cocktail de mesures
je pense qu'il a entendu effectivement
qu'ils n'avaient pas que
suite à ça qui va bien entendu dire que
toute façon on allait travailler jusqu'à
65 ans mais toi tu ne fais pas dans
l'hémicycle tes oreilles sont débouchées
c'est parce que j'ai des pages était pas
un herbicide petit 65 ans c'est encore
moi je dis cela dit on va travailler
plus longtemps on va bien entendu mon
haleine noyer plus longtemps puisque le
premier ministre l'a dit philippe moi je
crois beaucoup
mais paritarisme et tu le sais je crois
beaucoup à la discussion social ça fait
deux ans et demi qu'on dise si le
conseil d'administration doit décider
d'un équilibre et bien c'est à nous qui
nous qui décidons collectivement et on
verra donner le premier souvenir 65 ans
on s'est moqué des partenaires de
latence que la question de l'âge pivot
ou de l'âge des clips c'est la même
chose car c'est la même chose pour les
gens qui nous écoutent ces importants
ils attendent de savoir ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui ce qu'on nous explique en
commission et dans l'hémicycle c'est bel
et bien qu'aujourd'hui y aura toujours
un âge d'illégal qui à 62 ans mais qu'on
aura juste le droit de partir à 62 ans
mais que de toute façon y aura des cotes
à 62 ans
parce que pour la génération née avec
avant 75 on est plutôt sur un âge pivot
1 h déquilibre à 64 ans pour la
génération née après 75 et c'est dans
l'étude d'impact plutôt vers 65 ans ce
qui veut dire que pour cette génération
s'ils partent à 60 de ses 15% de décote
et pour la génération née après 90 pense
à nos enfants etc
pour cette génération là et bien eu ce
sera peut-être 66 ans et demi et
personne ne contredit là dessus dans
l'hémicycle donc c'est ça la réalité et
à mon avis c'est ça qu'il faut qu'ils
soient rendus aux questions notamment
sur l'âge déquilibre si vous voulez on
passa à l'assemblée nationale fait
passer aujourd'hui parce que sinon on
n'aura pas assez de temps on va quand
même regarder cette séquence pas moins
de cinq présidents de groupe jean luc
mélenchon en tête sont montés au créneau
cet après midi d'abord contre richard
ferrand qui présidait les séances et
aussi contre son interprétation du
règlement de l'assemblée nationale en
cause la question des amendements
identiques identique en toutes les
oppositions se lève
regardez ce que ça donne merci monsieur
le président je vais pas répéter les
arguments sur quel répondants
le bon monsieur le président eh ben vous
allez le démontrer avant de l'évoquer
non je ferais bien comme je l'entends
ben non parce que quand on fait un
rappel au règlement le fond d'endroits 1
sur le président si ce n'est pas un
meeting c'est l'assemblée nationale
conformément à l'article l article quoi
l'article sont du règlement intérieur
non non mais poursuit vous avez inventé
je ne sais quoi tout ça tout ça s'était
dit démocratie
je tenais à le souligner parce que ça
ira devant le conseil constitutionnel
bien je rappelle que la règle en vigueur
a été rappelé hier en conférence des
présidents
cela figure au procès-verbal cela n'a
fait l'objet d'aucune remarque la règle
a changé que tous les collègues
comprennent pas changé avec des
centaines de nos amendements vont tomber
on détourne complètement les débats avec
cette règle d'interprétation monsieur le
président lorsque ceux ci a été indiqué
de manière extrêmement claire en
conférence des présidents
il n'ya il n'y a pas eu ni demande
d'explication ni observation confrères
et on accueille stéphanie des pierres
qui nous a rejoints sur ce plateau
bonsoir stéphanie c'est vous qui suivez
cette réforme de près vous avez suivi
donc ces échanges tendus tout
l'après-midi qu'est ce qui s'est passé
précisément et pourquoi richard ferrand
s'est retrouvée sous le feu des
critiques et bien l'opposition lui
reprocher son interprétation du
règlement du palais bourbon le président
de l'assemblée a potassé le document il
cherche à contrer le déluge
d'amendements mais sans se faire taper
sur les doigts par le conseil
constitutionnel
il a donc établi cette règle quand des
amendements identiques sont déposés sur
différents articles au fil du texte
si l'un est rejeté tous les autres
tombes et vous l'avez vu bronca
immédiates de l'opposition surtout la
france est soumise et les communistes
qui se rendent compte que cela pourrait
faire tomber de très très nombreux
amendements et contrecarrer leur
stratégie d'obstruction pour les
insoumis richard ferrand a clairement
changé les règles du jeu en cours de
débat mais richard ferrand réplique
qu'il avait bien expliqué cette règle à
la conférence des présidents hier matin
il a même lu cet après-midi dans
l'hémicycle le compte rendu officiel de
cette réunion ce qu'on appelle le pv
alors richard ferrand at il bien
interpréter le droit est ce que
l'opposition s'est fait piéger elle
hier la pas tout à fait compris la
portée de ce que le président proposait
bref dès 15h cet après midi c'était
ambiance survoltée tellement de rappels
au règlement et de suspensions de
séances qu'on a même arrêté de les
compter
est ce qu'on sait au fond si cette règle
les amendements identiques tombait sur
l'ensemble des articles
combien il en resterait on a quarante et
un mille aujourd'hui eh bien on
passerait sous la barre des quarante
mille pas à mon normes sepa dragons ce
n'est pas le dire énorme et non parce
que le chiffre en fait de l'après midi
c'est 1184 c'est nombre d'amendements
qui devrait tomber ce sont surtout des
amendements communistes qui sont
concernés de quoi déclencher donc la
colère sébastien jumel qui a crié dans
l'hémicycle à l'ostracisation à des
députés du pcf on écoute vous avez
désigné la sève de ceux qui ont
contribué à construire le système de la
sécurité sociale comme vos adversaires
privilégiée nous prenons ça comme une
légion d'honneur monsieur le président
monsieur le président vous venez
d'inventer le 49-3 du président de
l'assemblée nationale avant le 49-3
gouvernementale est la fois sion vous
voyez les choses comme ça finalement
aussi a créé deux mille cinq cents
amendements ont fait un peu le récit je
vais d'un goûter nos allées le temps de
défense d'un amendement d'abord dire que
on a vu un richard ferrand chef de clan
plutôt que président de séance
d'accord déjà première chose il a
défendu le récit qu'on voit à l'oeuvre
depuis quelques temps qu'est celui qui
leur permet de faire leur passage en
force en renvoyant l'idée de
l'obstruction et du passage en force
vers l'opposition
c'est bien rodée tout ça ça convainc
personne mais dis donc c'est bien rodée
ensuite
hier on a déjà eu une première règle
avait effectivement été annoncé en
conférence des présidents s'étaient que
quand un article
mais maman que dans un même article s'il
ya des amendements déposés par les 16
députés du groupe même amendement
imaginons on dit le mot rêve
seize fois par les 16 députés et bien il
n'y a qu'un député du groupe qui le
défend cette première règle a été
annoncée hier
nous avons contesté parce que nous
disons points à la fois pour la sérénité
des débats mais aussi pour éclairer les
débats le fait qu'il les a célébrées qui
est seize députés qu'il explique
ça peut permettre d'éclairer mieux les
débats mais là on nous apprend quelque
chose de nouveau c'est que quand il ya
un amendement qui concerne un même
dispositif donc là je donne un exemple
nous nous avons dit qu à chaque endroit
où il y avait écrit régime universel
nous le remplacerons par régime
inéquitable et bien là c'est pas
simplement quand il est déposé 16 fois
par 16 députés c'est à chaque fois qu'il
intervient dans un article différents
donc sur des choses qui concerne des
normes extrêmement différente puisque en
fonction des articles vous ne touchez
pas aux mêmes se considéraient
préférerait on vous a piégé l'on sait
c'est que il a essayé cette technique
que nous y sommes opposés et que donc il
s'est finalement arrêté à 1184
amendements des députés communistes mais
que nous avons prévenu les autres
oppositions et que c'est bien qu'elle
ait fait bataille commune puisque ce
qu'ils s'apprêtaient à ce que
s'apprêtait à faire richard ferrand et
la majorité c'était bien ont supprimé
plusieurs milliers donc nous avons être
attentif vigilant et je pense que nous
avons à la fois tenu tête et c'est
important mais en plus gagné le fait qu'
il n'y ait pas de nouveau un muselage
alors la majorité va vous répondre
c'est vrai que c'est c'est rare de voir
toutes les oppositions vent debout comme
ça les républicains qui sont pas
exactement dans la même stratégie
d'obstruction
même s'ils s'opposent au texte répétez
le fameux c'est une stratégie passage en
force de la majorité un nom mais que
porte en lui une obstruction
systématique assumée par jean luc
mélenchon par le batteur du pays le plus
efficacement absolument tente mais il ya
aussi les républicains qui ont beaucoup
d'amendements - mais qui veulent eux
tout simplement aller vers une mesure
d'âge à 65 on va le dire on va le dire
rapidement eu aussi sont vent debout on
a entendu damien abad ça vous fait pas
un peu réfléchir attention vous prenez
des risques
l'opinion les français vous regarde va
peut-être effectivement expliqué un tout
petit peu la chose moi je suis
rapporteur donc j'étais j'ai fait
l'intégralité des débats en plénière et
en commission spéciale depuis maintenant
une quinzaine de jours bon les
amendements très nombreux qui n'ont
aucun sens en terme de co2
aucune porte et qui me dit qu'ils ne
proposent pas de droits qui ne demandent
pas le dispositif qui sont des
amendements de suppression ou simplement
de vocabulaire bon ça à deux effectifs
de 2 fn premier s'est essayé de bloquer
et d'embolie zay la machine pour paris
au bout et le deuxième c'est ma part de
marché - groupe dans la discussion
globale est effectivement dix neuf mille
amendements dans un premier temps de la
part de france a soumise est à peu près
10 fois moins de la part des communistes
et puis là je pensais comme nice 1 à
12000 euros soit la photo qui je me suis
fait avoir votre histoire vous fait que
le fasse à voir comme ça dans la
plénière et donc je mets un peu parti
mais un jeune en commission les de façon
à avoir c'est dans des deux façons une
part de marché importante
maintenant on reprend l'exemple de
madame roussillon europe remplace
système de retraite universel par
système de retraite inéquitable est ce
que vous pensez réellement que quand on
a quarante mille amendements passer
mille fois une minute deux minutes trois
minutes 3 4 minutes sur ce débat sur
inéquitable universel ça a du sens
neeson est en revanche on sait jamais là
la modification
elle a du sens et ça a été dit par
exemple parle par le groupe nr s'il dit
à chaque fois qu'il ya un décret il faut
rajouter en conseil d'état n'a un impact
juridique et richard ferrand l'a dit si
effectivement le même formulation
correspond à un enjeu juridique
différent évidemment il sera discuté de
façon totalement séparées fort merci
pour ce s'était exposé de cette
procédure parlementaire et d'utilisation
voir d'interprétation du règlement sur
les amendements identiques
comment ça va se terminer tout ça
stéphane et pour conclure
eh bien on ne sait pas trop à 18h30
enfin après trois heures trente de débat
de bataille de procédure on a repris
quand même l'examen du texte mais dans
un climat toujours très tendue après
trois heures de droit constitutionnel
les députés sont repartis sur les
articles sur les amendements alors on
verra ce qui se passe après c'est cet
épisode mais ce qui est sûr c'est que la
bataille procédurale à risque de durer
dans les prochains jours et si ça
continue et bien le texte sein des
bottes avec son avance et la dre
graphique
en sorte qu'elle soit vive et qu' il n'y
ait pas une n'est pas une majorité aidé
d'un président s'est écrié sont
désormais une pression le connais essayé
de l'expliquer à 49,3 ainsi car il y
voit clair c'est un débat que vous avez
sur ce plateau sur lcp merci beaucoup on
vous réinvite rats c'est un débat que
vous pouvez suivre d'ailleurs sur notre
antenne largement diffusé
merci stéphanie quelque chose me dit que
le feuilleton n'est pas terminé est ce
que vous aimez l'ena oui j'avais révéler
quelque chose j'avais postulé n'a quand
j'étais au lycée technique parce que
c'était vous voulez intégrer des
techniciens enfin des gens de métier
dans l'ena ça m'a été refusé je sais pas
où tu es ma bombe à fos allez me dire
encore moustachu certains mots de la
part de ça m'aurait intéressé de savoir
voilà comment se serait passé votre
séjour à l'est la police qu'elle va
justement vous restez avec nous on va en
parler de l'ena avec frédéric thiriez
qui va nous rejoindre dans un instant
vous savez qu'il a remis son rapport sur
la réforme de l'ena au premier ministre
hier l'ena la fabrique de nos élites qui
n'a d'ailleurs pas attendu à la crise
des jd jaune pour être au banc des
accusés
l'ena c'est quoi le problème on voit ça
avec maïté site et il y a un an à
strasbourg les gilet jaune manifeste
défiance contre les politiques et contre
l'école que beaucoup ont fréquenté l'ena
c'est un symbole en fait d'eux une école
de formation des politiques selon une
idéologie une idéologie qui consiste à
écraser le peuple est à prendre la main
et a gardé la main sur le sur la planète
entière mais d'abord qu'est ce que
l'aisne cas prend-il ses étudiants pour
conquérir si aisément les principaux
leviers de commande bref qui sont ces
énarques estimé critiquer mais dont
l'efficacité est reconnue même par leurs
adversaires bernard boucault fils
d'artisan
michel colin les experts comptables il
vient quand fils de professeur
d'université
martine aubry fut des hauts
fonctionnaires pour les français les nas
et l'école du pouvoir sur ces photos de
classes chercher le président jacques
chirac promotion vauban françois
hollande promotion voltaire ou encore
emmanuel macron promotion sans gore et
d'ailleurs qu'est ce qu'ils en pensent
emmanuel macron le candidat en 2017 se
défendent et face à ceux qui accusaient
les politiques de sortir du même moule
j'ai la tête d'un moule l'ena c'est pas
un moule c'est un moule pour qu'ils
veulent devenir ou qu'il avait déjà sauf
que deux ans plus tard emmanuel macron
président de la république ne tient pas
tout à fait le même discours s'agit pas
de dire que l'ena est mauvaise en soi au
contraire il s'agit de dire simplement
si on veut une réforme ambitieuse
voilà faut rebâtir résultat une mission
est confiée à frédéric thiriez lui même
énarques et dans son rapport il y à ce
verdict pas question de supprimer l'ena
il suffit de la refonder la renommée
école d'administration publique
pour les députés il y a du bon et du
moins bien
emmanuel macron sur la balle j'ai des
rides ce ressenti à chercher à égorger
le poulet pour si vous voulez apaiser la
colère populaire mais parfois en
proposant n'importe quoi ça n'est pas en
faisant trois semaines de stage avec des
polytechniciens que vous allez changer
drastiquement la manière dont les gens
voient le monde provient évidemment à la
diversité du recrutement on peut
diversifier les voies d'accès mais
attention il faut pas se retrouver dans
la situation reconstitue les prébendes
siècle et fils d'archevêque se retrouve
au meilleur poste ou dans les meilleurs
rangs de sortie ce qui a pu arriver dans
l'histoire je pense qu'aujourd'hui il
faut refondre totalement cette école
quitte à la supprimer et elle a remplacé
j'ai fait l'école de commerce et ensuite
j'ai fait une école de formation
politique puis ensuite j'ai fait du
terrain et je trouve que finalement le
terrain y'a qu'ça d'vrai le terrain et
qu'ça d'vrai bonsoir frédéric thiriez et
de l'acide être au rendez vous de notre
de notre émission vous êtes avocat vous
êtes ancien président de
ligue de football professionnel les
français vous connaissent bien et vous
êtes vous même et marque le premier
ministre le président de la république
pardonnez moi vous a donc missionné pour
réfléchir à la réforme de la haute
fonction publique d'abord vous lui avez
vous avez rendu à matignon 42
propositions hier et ô surprise c'est le
contraire du rapport borloo qui avait
classé sans suite immédiatement après et
bien vos propositions vont être reprises
pas tout mais déjà on a une série de
propositions reprises est ce que ça vous
a surpris
non ça m'a fait très plaisir parce que
le le débat sur lequel nous travaillons
depuis neuf mois avec mais avec ma
colistière parce qu'il se trouve que
j'ai deux compagnes de route qui sont
deux femmes ingénieures avec qui on a
travaillé pendant neuf mois
je suis très heureux que le premie
serait retenu l'essentiel des
propositions qui visent à faire quoi
la haute fonction publique est malade il
ya un fossé qui se creuse entre les
français et leurs dirigeants qu'ils
soient politiques ou hauts
fonctionnaires souvent les français
derrière ne le distingue pas les deux
moi mon rôle c'est d'essayer de combler
ce fossé
les gens ont le sentiment que les gens
qui décident pour eux ne sont pas
proches de leurs préoccupations qu'il a
creusé le système universitaire depuis
des années et des années
le général de gaulle en 1945 avec michel
debré voulait créer l'ena pour avec deux
objectifs l'excellence et la
démocratisation l'excellence je pense
que nous sommes au rendez vous je pense
qu'on l'a atteint la démocratisation est
un échec
pourquoi avons-nous aujourd'hui dans nos
grandes écoles du service public 80 %
d'enfants de catégorie supérieure
souvent 80% d'hommes et pourquoi faut-il
monté à paris pour préparer les concours
c'est ce contre quoi je veux lutter à
plus de 10
et re cité les gens ne se reconnaissent
plus dans allons d'ailleurs fonctionne
d'abord du recrutement et pardonnez moi
réussir je ne vous ai pas saluer celui
qui vous écoutent attentivement et qui a
préparé une chronique justement sur sur
sept et n'a vu de nos de nos voisins
européens richard qui est correspondant
parisien du quotidien suisse le temps
commençons par le recrutement l'objectif
numéro un c'est quoi plus de diversité
n'est pas mais pas un concours à part
les diversités attention ne parlons pas
diversité au singulier parfum diversité
au pluriel diversité sociale bien sûr
n'est pas normal que 80% des élèves de
nous et de nos grandes écoles soient des
des enfants de catégories supérieures ce
n'est pas normal ce n'est pas ce que
vous voulez le général de gaulle michel
debré diversité géographique
pourquoi faut-il monté à paris pour
préparer les concours diversité par sexe
comment se fait-il qu'à l'école
polytechnique il n'y ait que 20% de
femmes et kalenna il n'y ait que 30 % de
filles au concours externe ça n'a pas
possible pour plus de diversité au
pluriel vous vous proposiez un concours
spécial un concours spécial pour les
élèves défavorisés nations de leur
situation économique passe mais alors si
je comprends bien pas seulement
important parce que le sacro-saint
concours unique à la méritocratie à la
française ça aurait été quelque chose de
leurs voeux mais d'abord c'est d'abord
ça n'est pas vrai historiquement
puisqu'il y a déjà existé en 1982 1983
je m'en souviens j'étais sorti de l'ena
eu ce qu'on appelle une troisième voie
qui était ouverte
précisément à la diversité notamment
c'était comme sciences po avec les zep
l'exemple des zep de sciences po est un
merveilleux exemple mais je vous le
semble suffire
le premier ministre n'a pas ouvert la
porte à cela il a ouvert la porte en
revanche aux classes égalité des chances
avec 20 nouvelle prépa et un quota de
boursiers alors 7 mais pas beaucoup
une proposition que nous faisons
évidemment il faut d'abord et avant tout
que ont créé de nouvelles classes
préparatoires
en tout les dans tous les territoires
une par région au moins j'en ai j'ai
cité 20 classes 400 élèves
une au moins par région y compris
outre-mer pour que chacun est une chance
de préparer les concours sans forcément
monter à paris c'est une chose la
deuxième question c'est faut-il un
concours spécial pour cette population
d'élèves un oral unis c'est une question
qui est en débat au gouvernement moi je
les prends débat la porte n'est pas
fermée mais la porte n'est pas fermée
heureusement on a un débat il faut il
faut que le public d'ailleurs débattent
le gouvernement les parlementaires les
orgueils organise un syndicale c'est une
question qui se pose
moi je suis pour je vais vous dire
pourquoi si on veut des résultats à
court terme en termes de diversité il
faut tenter la chose même à titre
expérimental pour quatre ans cinq ans
donc et ouvrir la porte à un autre
concours en cours spécial essiane avec
les mêmes épreuves avec les mêmes
épreuves donc c'est pas un concours au
rabais avec les mêmes épreuves mais un
nombre de places garantir disons 10 15%
comme l'a dit le conseil d'état donc
nous sommes bordé juridiquement il était
temps mettre un peu sonné dans cette
dans cette école là et faire des
propositions pour plus de diversité
bouscule favoriser l'accès aux grandes
écoles pour toute la population c'est
une bonne chose mais moi je pense que ça
ne suffit pas ce qu'on peut y rentrer
dans le cadre des diversités vous
signaliez et ressortir complètement
uniformiser et donc parce que l'entrée
c'est important mais la sortie à ce que
le décalage que vous que les français
mettent entre leur vécu et le vécu de
ceux qui sortent de l'ena et contient
moult effets même moule
je suis assez d'accord avec ce que dit
monsieur martinez en fait parce que
j'avais des propositions formation on
est bien mais sur la formation
d'abord le terrain le terrain je suis
d'accord ce que les français reprochent
à nos fonctionnaires c'est l'éloignement
du terrain
ils sont loin des préoccupations des
gens concrètes de terrain parce
qu'aujourd'hui les stages c'est la
préfectorale ou la nuit là et va
consentir pour les baies l'ambassade
anena le tronc commun pour tous les
hauts fonctionnaires parce que bon on
parle beaucoup de l'ena mais faut pas se
focaliser sur l'ena il ya cette école en
france qui forme des hauts
fonctionnaires faut pas oublier que les
oui les administrateurs territoriaux
les commissaires de police les
magistrats judiciaires les met tous
ensemble pendant scène tous ensemble
tous ensemble
cette école pendant six mois et là ils
apprendront d'abord les valeurs du
service public quand même pas oublier
que quand on se dévouent au service de
l'état ça ça a du sens
ensuite la déontologie du fonctionnaire
du magistrat du policier et surtout des
missions sur le terrain 4 noir tel
terrain terrain on va voir qui pour
faire quoi
les administrations les collectivités
les hôpitaux les tribunaux les
commissariats de police où tous ses
élèves
cette pas ils seront par groupes de sept
dont un parent écoles seraient affectés
dans un dans un lieu hôpital
administration ville pour régler un
problème déterminer ensemble faire un
rapport étudier et proposer des
solutions
voilà le terrain avant trouvait à la
sortie de l'école n'oublions pas à la
sortie de l'école de la future et nate
s'appellera pas l'ena qui sera
profondément différente tout le monde
sur le terrain et pas tout le monde à
bercy voilà simplifiée est l'heure
d'aller aussi voir les syndicats parce
qu'il parle beaucoup de démocratie
sociale sans jamais l'avoir pratiqué
alors si vous avez tout à fait raison
c'est une des choses que je propose dans
le tronc commun un apprentissage de la
négociation sociale de l'histoire des
syndicats et des réalités économiques et
sociales
c'est fondamental alors on revient tout
de suite le message voulait demander
pourquoi ce goût du terrain s'est perdue
parce qu'au fond
normalement quand on se destine à être
haut fonctionnaire on sait qu'on va
avoir aux commandes
une agence de l'état ou une direction on
devrait s'intéresser à ce qui se passe
réellement
comment se fait-il que les énarques sont
devenus hors sol mais le métier d'abord
la france a changé depuis 1945 création
de l'ena le monde a changé
le métier d'administrateur de l'état a
changé autrefois l'administrateur de
l'état l'énarque c'était quoi celui qui
dans son bureau de bercy écrivait des
décrets des circulaires des mais ce
n'est plus ça aujourd'hui le métier
d'administrateur c'est d'être un manager
un manager des équipes qui écoute qui
imaginent des solutions
c'est un changement de culture que je
que j'appelle de mes voeux un énorme
changement de culture un les six mois
une norme formation commune quatre mois
sur le terrain on en a parlé trois
semaines de préparation militaire 3
vraiment des jeunes en scène nue c'est
l'engagement citoyen d'ailleurs je vais
vite parce qu'il ya beaucoup de choses
tout le monde n'a pas forcément joué le
jeu la magistrature on a senti ya des
réticences et nos voisins européens
cette ces trois lettres l'ena le relais
sous pas déjà absolument alors d'abord
l'ena est particulièrement connue parce
que quand on est correspondant étranger
d'un journal ou d'une télévision en
france
son but quasiment tous les jours sur
l'ena vous l'imaginez ou en tout cas sur
les énarques et alors d'ailleurs la
première chose c'est qu'il faut savoir
que très souvent le regard des étrangers
chez compulser un peu la presse est
admiratif et il n'y a pas longtemps un
homme d'affaires basé en suisse me
disaient les énarques france rime sont
formidables il parle bien ils
comprennent bien ils sont bien éduqués
c'est un plaisir de négocier avec eux
donc déjà une première fleur les
énarques non à l'étranger pas si
mauvaise réputation mais il ya un
problème myriam c'est qu'évidemment ils
sont très ambitieux et c'est le new york
times qu'il avait dit dans un article
parce que ils veulent tout de suite
accédé aux commandes de l'état et c'est
peut-être un peu ça le problème c'est la
différence entre être formé pour servir
l'état et se serviront de l'état et puis
il y à une deuxième chose vu de
l'étranger et là votre rapport touche à
cela c'est la question de l'origine
hybrides des élites au fond
quand vous regardez autour de la france
ce qui est caractéristique
il y a partout des castes il ya même un
livre qui a été écrit sur la haute
fonction publique à l'assaut de la halle
haas ou du monde par laurent mauduit
donc il y à des casques il ya par
exemple on le sait au royaume uni les
diplômés de oxford et cambridge il y a
en italie là la caste très particulière
de la banque d'italie qui est absolument
vénéré dans ce pays
il y as en allemagne aussi une haute
technocratie mais qui sont hybrides
parce qu'il partage le pouvoir avec des
élus de terrain ou dans le cas de
l'allemagne mais mc des fois avec des
syndicalistes qui ont qui sont montés
dans les sphères des pouvoirs donc au
fond votre rapport il s'inspire un peu
de l'europe
c'est un point important il propose de
métisser les élites ce qui est tout à
fait nouveau en france
enfin dernière chose moi j'ai un conseil
à vous donner maintenant il ya une
nouvelle mission qui vous attend ces
deux migrer à bruxelles à ce que vous
aurez constaté que le syndrome français
s'est déplacée vers l'europe
aujourd'hui c'est les eurocrates conclu
nic c'est le collège de bruges
lena européen qui est sous le feu des
critiques donc monsieur riez maintenant
vous paraît à bruxelles et vous proposer
de réformer le collège de bruges
beaucoup inspirés des exemples européens
qui sont très instructifs notre modèle
français n'est pas n'est pas de loin le
seul en europe il ya une chose que vous
venez de dire qui est très importante
c'est servir et pas se servir servir et
pas se servir
aujourd'hui ça ça veut dire des beaux
messieurs ça doit être la déontologie du
nouveau haut fonctionnaire que j'inspire
le neveu jacques michel debré moi je
bous on peut penser ce qu'on veut de
michel debré mais il avait quand même
qui vous a servi de guide à maxime a
inspiré je vais vous dire pourquoi parce
que michel debré disait qu'il ya quatre
vertus du haut fonctionnaire nécessaire
un servir l'état
ça va à peu près 1000 y avait trois
autres vertus servir l'humain est ce que
c'est là est ce que c'est le cas
aujourd'hui
je ne crois pas
le sens de la décision à dire prendre
une décision en mesurer les risques
parfois subi un échec dernière vertu
c'est le dernier et le dernier pardon
c'est le meilleur le sens de
l'imagination
voilà va se quitter sur cette petite oui
mais j'imagine je veux dire un mot s'il
vous plaît le malheur de l'ena c'est le
conformisme idéologique
il faut qu'on arrête avec ça il faut que
les hauts fonctionnaires soient créatifs
imaginatifs qui osent est d'avoir un
doute vous leur lancer cet appel on va
suivre d'ailleurs la manière dont ces
propositions vont être reprises et
scruter les nouveaux des marques vous
restez avec nous il reste 3 minutes et
on en est tous désolés mais les rives
rsa brochard pour sa chronique ce sa
journée à l'assemblée où est-elle ce
soir ce soir myriam on va parler musique
j'arrive tout de suite adhéré
de quoi vous parlez vous ce soir musique
oui exactement quelques notes sur un
piano une voix des violons vous le
découvrez alegres enfin j'espère que
vous allez le découvrir mais on est là
le titre qui représentera la france à
l'eurovision 2020 l'interprète s'appelle
tom l'aide c'est le fils de michel leeb
il chante bien il chante fort seulement
voilà myriam il chante en anglais
tu vois de baisse des mises
mais qui mélangent
je vois
voilà un refrain qui n'a pas plu du tout
aux députés jacques krabal également
secrétaire général de l'assemblée
parlementaire de la francophonie
hier en commission des affaires
étrangères ils protestaient le choix qui
est fait par la délégation tricolore
dans le cas de la chanson le titre de la
chanson en l'eurovision france
télévisions pour qui met en avant un
titre en anglais que je ne vais pas
citer et un refrain en anglais alors que
franchement je trouve cela très
interpellant et je connais votre
engagement pour la promotion de la
francophonie et donc c'est très
interpellé un que le ministre de la
culture lui a répondu ceci c'est vrai
que les paroles des couplets sont en
français mais le refrain est en anglais
ça m'a peut casser les oreilles ce matin
la radio
voilà alors inflammation du tympan chez
franck riester et audit interne impôts
andré vallini ancien secrétaire d'état à
la francophonie qui s'est empressé de
tweets et regarder sur france 2 je
découvre la chanson qui représentera la
france à l'eurovision
trois phrases en français et tout le
reste en anglais il devient décidément
de plus en plus difficile de défendre le
rayonnement de notre langue
affligeant et vous alors qu'est ce que
vous en pensez eh bien je vais vous le
dire mais même ce que monsieur vallini
n'a pas saisi
c'est la stratégie aujourd'hui tous les
jeunes européens comprennent l'anglais
ils suivent leur vision sur les réseaux
sociaux et potentiellement peuvent
encensé une chanson dont ils comprennent
à minima le refrain non ce programme
n'est plus ringard oui cette grand messe
musicale mérite qu'on s'y intéresse
alors que l'europe et est mal en point
l'eurovision c'est aussi comme son nom
l'indiqué est presque une autre vision
de l'europe une europe qui ne serait pas
à limiter à 27 états membres une europe
qui intègre la norvège l'albanie la
suisse la turquie et israël
l'eurovision c'est aussi la comédie
musicale des enjeux sociétaux et
géopolitique regarder 1969 l'autriche se
retire du concours refusant participer à
une édition organisée à madrid en pleine
dictature franquiste 1978 durant la
prestation israélienne la télévision
jordanienne suspens la retransmission et
diffuse des images d'un bouquet de
jonquilles 2004 conchita vue réveil
l'europe aux problématiques de genre
bref même
la chanson de tom allen ne soulève pas
de questions politiques majeures même si
elle est en franglais et on sera tous
devant le poste le 16 mai prochain
merci beaucoup va errer on apprend des
choses merci beaucoup babolat il a peu
de chances à notre frenchie y croire aux
normes à lev dodine recenser les
bookmakers merci beaucoup fait une
marque belge est revenue en plus de
tâtonner seront interprofessionnelle de
demain
c'est vrai les manifestations vous
l'avez fait merci richard wehrli merci
frédéric terrier d'être chercheur et
nous détailler vos propositions pour
changer
léna et la haute fonction publique très
belle soirée à vous et à demain
[Musique]